[Applause]
[Music]
hello hello
[Applause]
thank you for following that
introduction I appreciate the hello and
operating engineers local 77.
I might know from the time I announced
for the United States Senate when I was
a kid I had the support of the operating
engineers I love you all thank you thank
you thank you you guys have found 122
years ago that's not when I got indoors
skill workers operating all kinds of
construction equipment it can't be a
better place to talk about the progress
we've made together how it's working
with the country and how our by the
police sit down I've failed to tell you
to say that to you thank you
you know uh
I'm gonna just say at the front end this
ain't your father's Republican Party
this is a different deal right now and a
minority the party uh the mega I call
the mega Republicans are control the
party and uh they're in Congress
threatening to undo all the stuff that
you've helped me get done
that's why I'm here today because you
and the American people should know
about the competing economic visions of
the country that are really at stake
right now
I'm here in this Union Hall with you uh
when just two days ago the Speaker of
the House Kevin McCarthy went to Wall
Street to describe the microeconomic
vision for America
and it's very clear they've laid it out
I know when I was telling you it was
going to happen I'm telling folks they
looked at me like that can't happen well
guess what it's attempted to try to
happen now massive cuts and programs you
count on massive benefit protected for
those at the top a lot of you know all
the tax cuts go to the top none of the
bottom
the threat of defaulting on America's
debt for the first time in 230 years
we've never ever fallen on the debt and
it would destroy this economy
and who do you think will hurt the most
you hard-working people the middle class
the neighbors I got raised in not the
Super wealthier the powerful but working
folks and that's what I want to talk
about today
you know
and I know where I S you know where I
stand I make no apologies and I mean
this sincerely for being the most
pro-union and prison in American history
come on
it's not just because I grew up in the
office because it's true
you know when I speak to the Business
Roundtable on the marketing mucks are
good a lot of decent people
the very all the business enterprises
they look at me like hey guys don't jump
okay
but all kidding aside you know they look
at me like why am I always talking about
unions I say because you know they don't
appreciate how damn hard you all work
how damn it hard it is for you to get it
to be able to become something other
than an apprentice it takes four years
to train an apprentice just like going
back to school
tell Business Leaders all the time I
tell them that I'm pro-union because
union workers are the best workers in
the world and you are the best not not a
joke
that's the God's truth
that is the gods of you the best in the
world
it's better or long term for them to
hire you because you get the job done
you get it done on time and ultimately
it's cost them less when they hire you
so I've said many times Wall Street
didn't build America the middle class
Built America and unions built the
middle class that's a fact unions
[Applause]
one of the reasons I ran for president
was to rebuild the backbone the backbone
of this country the middle class
to grow the economy from the middle out
and the bottom up not from the top down
because when the middle class does well
the poor have a lighter up and the
wealthy do very well still and we middle
class you get a shot
we do well as well
and that's a clear contrast to my
friends on the other side of the aisle
these days it used to be didn't used to
be but it is now for decades they've
said that the best way to grow the
economy is from a top down trickle-down
economics well growing up I didn't see a
whole lot trickle down in our three
bedroom house with four kids in my Dad's
kitchen table
you know what trickle down didn't work
for us and it didn't work for a long
time and by the way it's not just what's
been in the migrant Republicans for the
last three four decades we've been
losing this ground
and you know and it's hollowed out the
middle class
you know rewarding wealth not work
rewarding companies moving overseas
because it gets cheaper labor look at
all a lot of you know maybe you come
from neighborhoods or in small towns or
like Scranton Pennsylvania where I came
from Claymont Delaware I come from
where used to be a lot of Pride because
we had business we had factories that
were working operating
in Scranton and Claymont there were 4
500 still workers there's none today
and not only do you lose the jobs you
lose a sense of Pride there's a sense of
who you are you begin to wonder does
anybody see me I mean this is silly
those of you from the Midwest travel
through the Midwest the towns where they
had a factory of pulling six eight
hundred people
you'll lose it you lose everything
a lot of people get this I'm not how
many of your friends you know of around
the country who've had this conversation
their son or daughter finishes their
education high school and comes to Mom
and Dad said Mom I can't stay there's no
work I gotta move I gotta leave
and why does that why these jobs go
overseas
because with cheap labor rather than
making the product here in America
we made it overseas they need a wider
economic inequity and along the way
losing something else as I said Pride
literally Pride it matters
my dad never went to college my dad was
a decent honorable man busted his neck
but here's my dad he talked about you
know everybody deserves to be treated
with dignity
with self recognizing their self-worth
now I made it sincerely not not it's not
a joke this is something I feel my gut
not just my heart and my heart
you know how many of you
know what it's like growing up in a
community where that factory does shut
down
where the community gets hollowed out it
gets hollowed out literally
folks trickle down economics doesn't
work
and together we've been doing everything
we can to turn things around
and with your help one of the first
things we did was pass the American
Rescue plan with not one of the other
team voting for it
it helped
help vaccinate our nation and deliver an
immediate relief to folks who need it
the most to get our economy back on
track it puts small businesses back in
business and it worked it provided
increased employment
and then I signed the bipartisan
infrastructure law making the case that
to have the strongest economy in the
world we have to have the best
infrastructure in the world how in God's
name can we lead the world with the
second rate infrastructure the best
roads the best Bridges the best airports
the cleanest water high-speed internet
so much more
can you believe that we used to be the
best infrastructure rated number one in
the world no we're rated now
internationally we're right at number
13.
13 in the world the United States of
America is rated 13 in the world
and guess what
that's where you that's where you come
in to get us back on top
we've announced over 25
000 infrastructure projects so far
over four thousand
over in 4 500 citizen towns across the
country range from ports and airports
wind and solar projects Operating
Engineers are going to be the biggest
through the biggest groundbreaking for
new and updated roads and bridges and so
much more
matter of fact lieutenant governor
always grabbed me for one Bridge already
she grabbed me when I just walked in
don't there you are God I don't blame
you
[Applause]
I told her we view the Eastern Shore
Maryland as the western shore of
Delaware
and also the bidens all come from
Baltimore
going all the way back to the early
1800s
from Baltimore
you know you're look you're the one
they're going to train this is not
hyperbole it's a fact you're going to
transform America you the operating
engineers are going to transform America
and it can't get done without you
without you can't get done that's I mean
it's just there's certainly is this fact
obvious
and so when we when we rebuild America
and I mean literally rebuild America
we're going to buy American you know
I've gotten a lot of criticism
because
[Applause]
there was a law passed in the early 30s
hit by America but no president's mainly
made much paid much attention to it what
it means is the money that Congress
gives me to allocate to spend on
projects whether it's a new deckerman
aircraft carrier or building an
interstate highway or a bridge you know
I get to say it has to be American
Products American workers
every Federal project built by American
workers using American Products creating
American jobs is what I've done since I
become president
I announced
and by the way it's consistent with
international trading agreements I
announced new standards require all
construction material used in the
federal infrastructure project have to
be made in America the lumber the glass
the drywall the fiber optics so much
more and guess what it creates jobs down
the line
and here's something else
decades ago the United States used to
invest over two percent of its entire
gross domestic product all the money we
spend on research and development we led
the world in research today we invest
less than one percent we used to rank
number one in the world in research and
development now we rank number nine in
the world how in the hell does that
happen
China was number eight that decades ago
today number two and we're number nine
and a lot of countries are closing in
fast
I don't want to wish any other country
well we have the best scientists
researchers and people in the world how
in God's name do we letting this happen
I'm serious think about it
that's why with your help
I signed the law that initially when I
suggested that people thought what are
you doing
it's called the chips and science Act
and guess what
I asked the CEOs of this company and
I've met with them all you know the
Fortune 500 companies
Etc
I asked them when the United States
government invests in a considerable
amount of resources in New industry does
that encourage or discourage private
investment
to a person everyone says it
significantly encourages the willingness
to bring private Capital off the
sideline
and that's how we bring new key parts of
this supply chain back to American
semiconductors as all you know these are
small computer chips besides the tip of
my little finger
effectively everything in our lives from
our cell phones or automobiles
refrigerators most sophisticated weapon
systems in the world and opposes and
possesses so much more
I want to remind everyone America
invented this computer chip we invented
it
by investing in going to the Moon a
while ago okay
we increase the sophistication many
times over we made them smaller faster
and more powerful
and over time
we went from producing 40 percent of the
world's chips down to 10 percent
despite our leading the world in
research and Design
how's that happen I'm pleased I mean
deadly earnings you have to be a rocket
scientist to figure this out how did
that happen
we all saw during the pandemic
when things slowed down in the Far East
where we proported so many of our
computer chips what happened
people all of a sudden didn't know all
of a sudden the public became educating
what a supply chain is people never
talked about it before
supply chain is when that Factory closes
down in the in the South Pacific guess
what there's not enough chips to build
automobiles in Detroit
shut down families get hurt
example every new vehicle and built in
America needs roughly 3 000 of these
chips per vehicle
during the pandemic as you may remember
automobile auto companies couldn't get
enough of these chips
prices went up because the price of cars
was through the ceiling inflation
biggest truck cost for inflation
but now all over the country companies
are investing
in America not just American companies
but foreign companies I asked the large
South America the South excuse me South
Korean company why they're investing in
American computer chips the bill the
factories here
they said because you have the best
workers in the world they said not me
we do
and guess what
it went from a relatively small
investment you know how much you're
investing now
400 billion dollars
400 billion dollars in advanced
Manufacturing a record amount of
investment back at home in any time in
our history for example in Ohio
I visited what I call the field of
dreams about a thousand acres outside of
Columbus where intel was committed 20
billion dollars to build they call a new
chip Fab a factory they call them Fabs
and guess what it's going to hire a hell
of a lot of people seven thousand people
building the their guests and you're all
going to get paid the prevailing wage at
those
by the way
and the other five thousand people
working full time in these factories
when they're built and they're bigger
than football fields the size these
factories
guess what
average salary a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars a year and you do not
need a college degree to have the job
well the same stories up in New York
State Texas Arizona Idaho
jobs in both construction and operating
these Fabs they're about the size I said
a football fields jobs that pay an
average of a hundred thirty thousand
dollars a year permanent
jobs that don't as I said require a
college degree it matters
don't take my word for it listen to the
recent headlines of the Wall Street
Journal not what I call a left-wing
paper
it says America is back in the factory
business that's the headline
Fortune Magazine
Fortune Magazine headline bidens massive
manufacturing push is working
Financial Times
transformational change Biden industrial
policy begins to bear fruit
folks
it's barefoot because all of you
because I have confidence in you
because you're getting the job done
folks my economic plan is the blue
collar blueprint to rebuild America
and that's not all
I get how folks are struggling with
inflation
I grew up in a house where the price of
gas went up you felt it it was the
discussion at the kitchen table not a
joke
inflation has been a global problem
because of two things a pandemic the
disrupted these Supply chains around the
world
Putin's war in Ukraine which disrupted
energy supplies and food supplies
causing the price of everything from
eggs to wheat to go up
we have a lot more to do but inflation
has been coming down nine months in a
row
it's down 45 percent and again we can do
we have to do more still a big problem
the way I think about it is the way my
dad talked about it around the kitchen
table
he said how much are monthly bills
how much you have left to pay for all
the Necessities when you pay your major
bills
and will there be enough at the end of
the month just have a little bit of
breathing room just a little bit of
breathing room
many of you been through that
well that's why with your help I signed
the thing called the inflation reduction
Act
there's more
more than one day one way to bring down
the cost of raising a family or
controlling a household that's all the
other expenses you can bring them down
that don't directly aren't counting
inflation bring them down it reduces the
pressure on you give it a little bit of
breathing room for example America's pay
Americans pay more for prescription
drugs than any other Advanced Nation on
Earth the same exact drug
you pay more
in the United States and France Germany
England wherever you go
I've been fighting for years as a
senator and vice president
to allow Medicare to negotiate the price
of those drugs to negotiate the price
guess what
we allowed we allowed the veterans of
the department to be able to negotiate
price for the veterans but we never but
that that's been in place but we've
never allowed Medicare to do this but
finally finally we beat big Pharma we
got it done again without a single
Republican vote
look it's had a profound impact on so
much more and there's so much more to
come how many of you know anybody with
diabetes
okay well guess what
you're not you're now paying 35 bucks
instead of 500 bucks a month for that
insulin
[Applause]
God love you man
by the way you know you talk about a lot
of people's dignity I was in Virginia
about before I got this passed at a town
meeting
this is about a year ago and a woman
stood up she said she didn't break down
but she was very emotional he said I
have two children with diabetes
I don't have enough private insurance
to be able to pay for it we have to we
have to cut the dosage we have to trade
off
how do you feel as a parent
looking out your child knowing if you
can't get them the drug they need it may
affect their life and they're very very
very existence
well guess what
that's changed
one in 10 Americans has diabetes
every day Millions use insulin to
control the diabetes so they can stay
alive
insul's been around for over a hundred
years
and when the guy invented he didn't even
patent him because he thought everybody
should be able to access it you know how
much it costs these companies to make
that insulin
t-n-t-in dollars to package it maybe
another dollar and a half maybe two
but they're charging four five six seven
hundred dollars a month
and folks
big Pharma has been unfairly charging
and making record profits
not anymore
we began by capping the cost of insulin
is 35 a month for seniors initially I
proposed it for everybody
I couldn't get enough folks to a guy
lost a couple Democrats
but we're coming back at it and that's
not all
the law and when I told people that it
was going to be 35 bucks a month when
the cup passed last year I don't blame
to look at me like Yeah Joe
didn't occur until January 1 this didn't
start
well guess what happens this law brings
Total Drug costs down the main the way
people need
how many of you have had cancer and or
know someone who does
this law will cap out-of-pocket costs
for seniors on Medicare at a maximum
thirty five hundred dollars a year for
every single drug they have to take
every single job this year
and then the following year
it's a maximum of two thousand dollars a
year even if you're taking a twelve
thousand fourteen thousand sixteen
dollar thousand dollar cancer drug
it's a game changer and it's fair this
is nothing radical it's just fair
you don't have to pay these prices in
other countries
inflation induction react also makes the
most significant investment in dealing
with climate ever anywhere in the
world's history
and by the way
by the way
I can digress for just a moment before I
announce my plan which is most
consequential one in literally history
of the world know what countries ever
done it we've never done America's never
seen it I went to my friends in the
union movement because you're all
worried I'd understand you you've been
told that you work on on global warming
is going to cost you jobs
I sat down with one of my good friends
the head of the ibw just retired going
to retirement party for him this week
and I laid out you may remember here and
I getting beat the hell getting beat out
me but I didn't care about the
environment
and then I met with a lot of you guys
met with your International presidents
and I said you want to make some real
money if this is where you're going to
make it because you're gonna it's gonna
help by the way
guess what
when we're dealing with the ibw they're
going to put in
000 charging stations 550
000.
you all are going to build on the roads
and highways and the bridges that get
there
it's going to generate incredible
incredible economic growth
for example and also families aren't
don't even part organized labor they get
a thousand dollar year savings by
providing a rebate when they buy a new
efficient Appliance or weatherizes their
home to get a tax credit for appreciated
heat heat pumps rooftop solar energy so
they can afford to do it and they get a
tax credit for doing it and the
long-term savings for them is
significant
without going to everything it also
provides tax credits for electric
vehicles
new or used because we're convinced that
the companies are going to move let me
back up
I called a meeting of all the the
American automakers to the South lawn of
the White House
Last Summer
the summer before
and I talked about the need for us to
have to transition
and at the time Mary Barrett is the
President of General Motors
was suing the state of California
because they said they had a air quality
standard higher than the federal
government
and the argument was they couldn't do
that
well I got a call from her four or five
days later saying I dropped the suit
we've decided we're going to go all
electric by 2035.
guess what
we also put in all electric over the
near term be providing significant tax
exemptions if you purchase a used or or
of new via all-electric vehicle it's a
game changer
and by the way anybody who doesn't think
we have global warming hang out with me
man
travel every major fire I've been to you
know more land has burned in two years
to the ground because of global warming
more land because of fires as a
consequence of the long uh the the
utility poles you put up and all the
rest all of it more land is burned than
the entire state of Maryland
literally all the land you read about
Vernon and from Arizona to Idaho and Out
West more land burned to the ground and
homes in the process than the entire
size of the state of Maryland
and all of you in this room are playing
a big gonna play a big part
most charging stations those roads and
access points and so much more
because you're going to be building it
folks look around at our economic plan
is working
we've created more than 12 000 brand new
jobs in two years that's more than any
president American history has created
in four years in four years
[Applause]
unemployment is at 3.5 percent near a
50-year low
and offer minorities well for African
unemployment is African-American
unemployment is down low Hispanic across
the board
nearly eight hundred thousand
good pain manufacturing jobs the fastest
growth in 40 years
where in the hell is it written
and it says we can't be the
manufacturing capital of the world again
I don't I don't know where that's
written it's going to be us
you know this better than anyone
it's an all-time record for construction
jobs
as I said where is it written we can't
manufacture more than anybody in the
world and by the way we've made all this
progress in a fiscally responsible way
all the talk of these guys I'll get to
this in a second but how they're going
to cut spending and the like
in my first two years in office
I brought the deficit down by a record
1.7 trillion dollars all we spent still
less than 1.7 trillion dollars
inflation reduction going to bring down
deficits by hundreds of billions more in
the decades ahead and again not a single
Republican voted for it let me be clear
again under my plan no one earning less
than four hundred thousand dollars has
seen nor will see as long as I'm
president a single solitary Penny raised
in their taxes not a single penny
and we're able to make huge progress for
the country but making the biggest
corporations begin to pay their fair
share
you all pay your you pay more than a
fair share no I'm serious
and by the way I come from the corporate
capital of the world I was a Senator for
36 years in Delaware more corporations
Incorporated in Delaware than every
other state in the Union okay
so I'm not one of these guys that
corporations are all bad they're not but
it's about time they start to pay their
fair share
let me ask you a question
not a joke how many of you think the tax
system is fair in America
oh I'm sure you guess what
you may remember my talking about when I
first got elected there were 55 of the
Fortune 500 companies that made 40
billion dollars in profit in 2020. and
guess what they paid zero not a single
penny in taxes
not a single penny
I said it was wrong
so I did something outrageous
I was able to impose a 15 tax my God 15
percent
[Applause]
you'll pay more now you pay twice that
how many construction workers
firefighters teachers cops
would be happy to pay 15 percent
you know I love these guys telling me
what they value my dad used to have an
expression he said don't tell me what
you value show me your budget I'll tell
you what you value
let me tell you what I value compared to
the other side
well I'm here in this Union Hall I would
use speaker McCarthy just got finished
speaking to Wall Street two days ago and
speaking to the United States Congress a
few hours ago
and what we described as the Mega's
economic vision
it was days before tax day
do you think he told the wealthy and
Powerful it's about time they step up
and start paying a fair share
not a word
do you think he told a billion dollar
companies to stop stop stashing profits
and tax Havens out off the coast and
shipping jobs overseas I didn't hear any
of that did you
instead he proposed a huge cuts and
imports and very important programs that
millions of hard work in a middle-class
Americans count on
all the while he and the mega officials
are separately pushing for more tax
giveaways and overwhelming benefits to
the wealthiest Americans and biggest
corporations folks
it's time the same old trickle-down
dressed up maggot clothing is worse than
ever
let's be clear
a plan has details
the plan is straight that's with the
American people McCarthy comes along and
delivers a speech with no not a plan
actually in some sense is pretty simple
for example he talked about limiting
spending we're all for that man let's
limit spending
look at what he didn't say he didn't
tell you exactly how much he wants to
cut
but the house leading Republican
proposal would cut critical programs
so-called discretionary spending by 22
percent
that would mean cutting the number of
people who administer Social Security
and Medicare meaning longer wait times
higher costs for child care
significantly higher prequel College
higher costs for housing especially for
older Americans people with disabilities
families of children veterans 30 million
fewer veterans outpatient visits leaving
our brave warriors to get checkups and
mental health services and treatment and
subsidies and substance disorders out in
the cold tens of thousands of people
suffering from opioid the epidemic would
be denied treatment they need for
recovery
a MAG of 22 percent cut undermines rail
safety
food safety border security clean air
clean water it's not hyperboles the fact
is look it up
Maggie republicans in Congress want to
defund
the FBI and the police
talk about the funding they don't like
the FBI
maybe arrested some of them
it's outrageous
I might think about it to fund the FBI
Mega republicans in Congress have
introduced a bill that could take food
assistance away from as many as 10
million kids people 4 million children
and put them at risk of going hungry
the wealthiest country in the world
Maggie Republican Congress support Cuts
in Medicaid that could lead millions of
people to losing their health care
including and working poor people with
disabilities
and here's the thing
does the painful do these painful Cuts
actually help the deficit do they
actually reduce cost
well the answer is honest answer is no
the very first build of the House
Republicans passed was to get rid of the
law I signed to crack down on Wealthy
tax cheats
I'm talking about the multi-millionaires
and the billionaires
what does it mean
well it was estimated by all the experts
that they kept cutting the number of IRS
agents not not doing your taxes
but doing the incredibly sophisticated
taxes required to do the
multi-billionaires and millionaires
and guess what
it was estimated that it would in fact
reduce the deficit because we bring in
more money
more money from a super wealthy we start
to pay their fair share make it easier
wealthy to get away with cheating on
their taxes they wanted to get rid of
these IRS agents well that's what they
proposed again
and folks or you pay your taxes others
aren't
they want to increase the deficit and
get rid of the corporate minimum tax of
15 15 percent
look I want to make sure that the two
trillion dollar Trump tax cut that he
passed in his last term only term
for two Trill well I didn't mean it that
way
I didn't mean that
[Applause]
but they they want to take that two
trillion dollar tax cut that
overwhelmingly help the super I don't
know how many you got you guys benefit
from that tax cut
to make it permanent
and that tax cut in the previous four
years ballooned the deficit balloon the
deficit by over 40 percent
I want to continue it and by the way the
tax cuts didn't help very much
overwhelmingly benefit the wealthiest
the biggest corporations the super
wealthy families making more than for
example four million a year got an
average tax cuts of 175 thousand dollars
how much did you get
Niagara republics in Congress also want
to repeal the inflation reduction act
which will increase the deficit because
right now allowing Medicare to negotiate
drug prices they have to pay to provide
for a prescription drugs for the elderly
guess what that saves the government a
hundred and sixty billion dollars
because they're paying that much less
and people are getting the benefit
and by the way the previous
administration cut the number of IRS
agents by reviewing this complicated tax
returns that was part of it as well the
inflation reduction act gives the IRS
agents the need to get the number the
number of Agents they need to get the
taxes owed
it was estimated that it would recover
over a hundred billion dollars in tax
and soda if they were able to have these
agents looking at them
and you know all of this reduces the
debt that we've that I proposed by 240
billion dollars over the next 10 years
and the Maggie Republicans want to
repeal it
folks that's the economic agendas
spending cuts for work in the middle
class folks
Americans and tax cuts for those at the
top of the the pile
it's not about fiscal discipline it's
about cutting benefits for folks that
don't seem to care they don't seem to
care much about
it's about finding ways to squeeze out
more of America's middle class they
should be getting tax release themselves
not to super wealthy
imagine denying some veterans the
Medicare they need the medical need the
medical care they need so the big
Corporation can keep paying their taxes
I felt very strongly about the
legislation we passed that affected the
ability of us to take care of those
folks who were died as a consequence are
sick because of burn pits
my son was one of those kids
spent a year in Iraq
I've been in and out of Iraq and Iran
Iraq and Iran but Iraq not Iran I
misspoke Iraq and Afghanistan over 30
times
when I saw him when he was in Iraq and
Baghdad
he was less than a couple hundred yards
from one of those burn pits they're 10
Deep feet deep the size of football
field
and they burn everything in it from jet
fuel to toxic a lot of you guys know
folks were firemen how many people came
back with cancer the consequence of
going to 9 11 and they finally took care
of them
well I was determined to take care of
these kids
and we got a past
we got a past
imagine trading off less food
inspections
so the wealthy can have a giant tax cut
imagine denying poor and disabled
Americans on Medicaid Medicaid not
Medicare
treatment they need for asthma diabetes
so the wealthiest Americans keep
cheating on their taxes
and by last saying every wealthy
American cheese in their taxes
but you have we have a thousand
billionaires in America
know the average tax rate they pay
eight e i g h percent
eight percent
I proposed a better way
how about starting with big oil
guess what we're still going to need
some oil
but we made they made up 200 billion
dollars in profit last year
in the middle of a global energy crisis
because they weren't reinvesting in
refineries
and the receipt in the process an
additional 30 billion dollar subsidy
from the taxpayers
I want to cut those wasteful subsidies
for Big Oil
saving taxpayers 30 billion dollars
Margaret Republicans want to protect
those subsidies for Big Oil
should we just finally beat big Pharma
by giving Medicare the power to
negotiate lower drug costs I want to
keep going
republicans in Congress want to hand big
Pharma back to power back in power
just think about it
we have now about a thousand as I said
billionaires
their average tax is eight percent as I
said it's wrong
that's why I proposed a billionaire
minimum tax no billionaire should be
paying less for of a tax rate than a
school teacher or firefighter
but folks here's this is really
dangerous Mega Republican Congress are
threatening to default on the national
debt the debt that took 230 years to
accumulate overall
overall
unless we do what they say they say
they're going to default unless I agree
to all these wacko Notions they have
default
would be worse than totally
irresponsible
it would mean Cuts in Social Security
Medicare higher interest rates for
things like credit cards car loans
mortgages working people middle class
seniors would pay the price for the
entire economy would be at risk
America's never defaulted on our debt
which has accumulated over 200 years
let's remember the last Administration
alone
increased the national debt by 40
percent in four years yet every single
year they passed they passed the debt
limit every single year
in a speech to Wall Street
the speaker failed to guarantee he would
for to be the first speaker not to
default on our debt
let's be clear
if he fails the American people will be
devastated
not just 10 or 20 years from now but
today
the speaker likes to quote his hero
Ronald Reagan who I knew because I was a
senator
he doesn't quote everything Reagan said
Reagan said debt ceiling brinkmanships
threatens the holders of government
bonds and those who rely on Social
Security and veterans benefits in the
United States as a special
responsibility to itself into the world
to meet its obligation he goes on to say
it means we have a well-earned
reputation of reliability credibility
two things that set us apart from the
rest of the world
that's what Ronald Reagan said
Donald Trump
seeking to increase the debt limit while
he was doing what he was doing
he said quote I can't imagine anybody
ever even thinking about using the debt
ceiling as a negotiating wedge
I guess he didn't know the new Mega
Republicans he bred
America
is not a deadbeat Nation we meet our
obligations
and I made clear to speaker McCarthy
about how we should proceed to settle
our differences and no one should do
anything to jeopardize the full faith
and credit of the United States America
instead by making threats of default if
I don't go along with what they want
which would be catastrophic of the
country
if we don't do it they say they're going
to let the fault take place take the
fault off the table
and let's have a real serious detailed
conversation about how to grow the
economy lower cost and reduce the
deficits
I've laid the first time in I said I'll
wait my budget on the table by March the
9th you lay your budget on the table and
then we'll negotiate
Maggie Republicans owe the people the
same
offer a plan not speeches offer a budget
the levels of American people exactly
what you intend to do and how you're
going to cut
what tax giveaways you plan to extend to
the super wealthy what it means for the
deficit
let me close at this
my economic plan for the middle class
is Transforming Our economy to be
stronger Fair more Innovative more
compared more competitive
that's where all of you come in
without you we can't rebuild America and
again that's not her part we cannot
rebuild America without you
you're part of the bowl plan to invest
in America that I have
in all of America including the places
and people who have been forgotten
you build the roads the bridges
you're going to take all those lead
pipes out of our system make it safer to
generate economic growth for the country
you get more you got more to do but we
made a lot of progress and we just got
to keep it going
because of you we're on the move
I can honestly say and I mean this I've
been doing this a long time but I've
never ever ever been more optimistic
about America
we just have to remember who we are we
are the United States of America there
is nothing beyond our capacity nothing
we've ever set our mind do we not been
able to do when we've done it together
so God bless you all may God protect our
troops thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hahaha
[Music]
foreign